blake shelton goes all out on easter
dressing up as a pink bunny it's one of
those once in a lifetime
you know moments but one person who
doesn't love it carson daly's
two-year-old daughter goldie i don't
want to ruin this for you on sunday the
45 year old country singer got into the
holiday spirit slipping into this pink
bunny onesie complete with bunny
slippers mittens and floppy ears
[Applause]
based on those laughs in the background
the voice coaches friends and family
we're here for it
[Applause]
blake shared that clip on instagram
alongside the caption happy easter
everybody you're welcome and his wifey
gwen stefani slid right into the
comments saying what we're all thinking
thank you
i think somebody that can make you laugh
constantly is very sexy
in fact the 52 year old no doubt singer
loved it so much she posted it on her
account too along with a super festive
tune quote happy easter from me and the
easter blakey
[Music]
festive right
i was only trying to impress gwen i
think i'm his biggest fan well blake and
gwen's pal carson daly spent sunday with
the love birds but his daughter was
totally freaked out by blake the easter
bunny oh my goodness the tv personality
shared this snap of his little girl in
blake's arms and that right there guys
that's the look of pure terror
carson captioned the snap quote goldie
is not so sure about this oklahoma and
if that pick wasn't funny enough
carson's today show co-host al roker
brought the laughs writing in the
comments quote hope uncle blake is
kicking in for the therapy that will be
needed it's very emotional as for gwen
her picks with blake were a lot more
cheerful that's the don't speak singer
grinning ear to ear next to her man i
mean the easter bunny
sometimes i just feel like i'm in a
dream but it's no surprise these two
went all out for the holiday
back in november gwen dished to et about
going back to oklahoma for thanksgiving
for the first time since their july
nuptials we have not been back there
since the wedding so i'm really looking
forward to it and we have a new house
there we have like a new life there so
it's gonna be it's gonna be our first
married thanksgiving very grateful very
excited the couple said i do last summer
in front of their closest friends and
family with their good pal carson
officiating it was like the perfect
amount of people it was so intimate it
was so exactly what it needed to be and
yeah it was just and not just the
wedding but the marriage is so fun and
i'm so into it so i feel very blessed i
love seeing like the smile on your face
you just seem like you're in the best
phase of your life would you say that's
true i'm in the best phase of my life
you feel more grateful than ever i mean
truly we do
and i just gotta say gwen and blake we
feel pretty grateful too thanks for this
excellent and happy moment
[Applause]
[Music]
you